O ne o
[Müzik]
ya boşver Benim bildiğim oğlum Hikayesi
adlı hikayenin Other Çünkü böyle bir
konuşma yapar mısın bu A diye
sorduklarında soruyor açtım baktım
onyedi yaş başarılı ve başarısız dedim
Eyvah Çünkü 17 yaşın hatırlamayacak
kadar uzaktaydı ama kendisi yakaladım
buldum ve konuşma hazırladım Öncelikle
sevgili seven çocuğum gibi ben teşhisi
hiperaktifin Hatta Hipo bu çocuk tedavi
etmiyorsun demişler ama annem maddi
durumu olmadığı için ama bu da böyle
büyür geniş bir alanda çalışırken önemli
bulaşık bir konuyu
yapabilecek kadar hafif bir insanın sizi
çok iyi anlıyorum ama ben başladım
hareket etmiyor farkındasın O yüzden
özür diliyorum Bunu biraz da bir şekilde
Muhtemelen ilk kez bir konuşmalı
ezbersiz olarak hazırladım
inanamayacaksınız Ama artık ezber
yapmaktan sanıyorum değil mi bazı
köşeleri çekip gitmeye başlamış O yüzden
arada bir nokta bakacağım Şimdiden özür
diliyorum bu Merhabalar ben Doğa Rutkay
var böyle bildim kendimi sonra hayatına
işine girdim önemli bir soyadı daha
doğal çıkartan olduğunu çok büyük
mutluluk duyuyorum bundan O ayrı bu da
dahil bütün genellemeler yanlıştır
diyorum içe verdiğin için sevdasıyım
başımızın belası bir adam biliyorsunuz
her şeyi dosdoğru kaskatı insanın Yüzüne
yüzüne söyleyen biri ama şimdi Şu
zamanda düşünüyorum da bize de gerçekten
böyle Dostlar lazımmış yani bize
gerçekleri değil hükmeden yüzümüze kendi
hatalarınızı
bu söyleyerek bizim başbaşa Kendinizi
yalnız bırakmayan Dostlar O nedenle
sevgilim için çok sevdiğim bir sözü da
var diyor ki Sahip olunması zorunlu tek
bir şey vardır ya yaradılıştan ince bir
ruh ya da bilim ve sanat tarafından
inceltilmiş bir O çok harika çok ışık
olan bir sözüdür bana yani Biz de şu
demiyor şu marka ayakkabı mutlaka giyme
lise son model iPhone kesinlikle
kullanmalısın üstü açık olağanüstü bir
araba olacak Hayır bunları söylemiyor
diyor ki kendini tanıyan ince bir Ruha
ihtiyacım var işte şimdi yaşadıklarımı
doğru değerlendirdiğimizde Bu ince ruhu
kişiler nasıl koştuğumu Aslında Buna da
sahip olabildiğini ve olduğumu anlıyorum
ve karşınızda buzu Şu sebeple
bulunuyorum olan bir şey olduğu için
Aslında ünlü
şimdiki dönemde ünlü olmak çok kolay bir
saniye içerisinde merhaba dedin döndü
anne oldu ya o kadar hızlı büyür var O
bizim dönemimizde özellikle çok ve
babamın döneminde bu kadar kolay bir şey
değildi ve ünlü tanımı benim hiç hoşuma
gitmeyen ama aslında beni oldukça zaman
zaman mutsuz eden başıma bela bir tanımı
tanımı gerçekten Çünkü neden az evvel
sevgili genç arkadaşım dedi ki Rutkay
Aziz'in kızı
kızı Evet
kızıyorum 24 yaşında Ankara sanat
tiyatrosu'nun başına geçmiş olur incecik
Yaşına rağmen
devrimciye ilerici
kişiliğiyle ünlü bir oyuncu olmuş Çok
önemli bir tiyatro yönetmeni olmuş
yirmibeş yaşındayken Nazım'ın şiirlerini
sahnede Atatürk'ün sinemada oynamış çok
büyük ve dev bitsin bu zamanlar Rutkay
Aziz'e benden oluyorum bu da hutbe
Aziz'in kızı bu işte Hikayem böyle
başlıyor babası Atatürk olan kız 17
yaşında küçücük omuzlarımın kocaman
koydular Artık sende bir şüphesi
yeni başlayan diyeceğiz şimdi 25 yıl
sonra ünlü olmak Şöhret olmak o kadar
kötü anlama gelmiyor benim için Ama
neler yaşadığımı sizlerle paylaşacağım
Evet adım Doğa miyim bir bakıyorum da ne
ve soyadımızı bye ya bu şey ya şey bu bu
ya kızın babasının adı karga bu kızı
suyunu tutkal oluyor bir yok bu değildir
okuruz dedikleri O kız benim ya bu kız
var ya işte babasını sayesinde ünlü
olmuştu babasını sayesinde şık sesini
kazandı babasının sayesinde Mimar Sinan
devlet konservatuarı'na girdi dedikleri
Kız
bu kadar güzel değil Burada çok kısaymış
Sanki ben modelleri oluyorum Market
olacak Bu uyku sorunu dedikleri o kız
Yani aslında şunu anlatmak istiyorum
kendini sürekli ispatlamaya çalışmak
zorunda bırakılmış bir çocuk yani
kocaman bir soyadı etiketiyle sizi
ittiriciler ve siz ok Ya aslında bilmeye
çalışıyorsunuz Aslı çok samimi
söylüyorum hayata 1-0 yenik başlıyor
başkası çünkü benim de ikiz evlatlarımın
olduğu gibi aslında Çünkü çok meşhur
babamız olduğu için sizin Kim olduğunuz
kimsenin umrunda değil ne düşündüğünüz
kimse Bunların ne olmak istediğiniz neye
dönüşeceğini biz bunların hiçbirine
ilgilenmiyorlar önyargılar var onlarla
geliyorlar var Lütfen samimiyetinize
güvenerek şunu söyleyeyim sizlerin
olduğunu Çünkü siz bakıyorsunuz ve
benimle ilgili kafanızı bir sürü şey yok
ve hızlı bir zaman şunu da beraber de şu
Bizi doğru
bir öyle böyle
değil derken onların içinde bulursunuz
benim hikayem denizinden böyle olduğunu
söyleyebilirim biz size Aslında
olduğunuz gibi değil buldukları gibi
bulmaya çalışıyor Bu insanlar ve
hepsinin bir sesi var bir hepsini bir
fikri var o etiketler ellerinde çal çal
çak çak çak yapıştırıyor her çok kötü
etiketlerle ve dediler ki en sonunda
babasının kızı okul hayatı boyunca süren
o parmakla göstermesinler
bir sebeplerle dürtmeler şişeyi kıza bu
şeyin kızı bak bir şey kızı şeyi kızı
bile tanımadı ona dönüşüyor ve o
zamanlarda Az evvel söyleyeyim Medya bu
kadar hızlı tuşa mı şey değil şimdiki
bir dakika içinde ünlü dolanıyorsun o
babamın yıllarda taşıdığı emeğine bir
disiplini hayatı boyunca
bozmadığı oturuşunu bana keklemek
istiyorlar yassı babamın emeğine babamın
soyadını Baba bunu kimliğiyle hemen bana
bu paylaştırmaya çalışıyorlar yani Benim
kim olduğum önemli değil bu sebeplerde
bütün ortaokul lise Yıllarım kendi
yolunu yürümek varken yani kendi yolunda
birçoğunuzun pazarı anlatan Kıymetli
hocalarım gibi bu perdede yaşarken iyi
oluyor Kendi Ben ben başka birim aslında
yani demekle içeceği ve geçtiğinde Yani
ne yaparsan yap günün sonunda babasını
sayesinde demekten fazla geçecekler mi
şimdi daha iyi anlıyor işte onyedi yaş O
elbise rendeliyoruz 17yaş var mıdır
dikiş Vallahi bak
buna çocukluktan çıkıyorsun çıkıyorsun
bir genç bir kadın olma yoluna girmeye
başlıyorsun
fırlatıyor ne oluyor Yeter artık ne
oluyor ben kendim nasıl tanıyacağım ve
onyedi yaşım çeşit tanışma mecburi
tanıtma
ve bir şekilde Benim sadece yalnızca bir
başına Ben olduğunu anlatmaya başladım
Sevgilim Burada başlıyor kendim onlara
tanıtır Ya aslında Şimdi anlıyorum ki
bir de tanınmaya başlamış birlikte
başlıyoruz O yüzden 17 yaşında Konuşma
yaparken yanıma çağırdım oturdum ses
Olmasın dedim ki gel bakalım on yıl
değil yıl geçti üstünden Biz neler
yaşadıkları İnsan bir tuhaf oluyor
oyunlara gittiğinde o günleri
hatırlamaya çalıştı daha zor adam oldu
doğaya hatırladım Tıpkı Böylesine güzel
bir
eğitim çatısı altında ışık sesinde o
merdivenlerden çok sevdiği şarkıyı
buradan [ __ ] inen doğayı hatırladım
çok genç çok sakar çok coşkulu enerjisi
hiçbir yarısını Yani insanlar bütün
anlayamadı hareketleri bir bedenin ve
yaşamımızı annesinden doğru hatırladım
Ben o zamanlar kendini bir yabancı gibi
bizde sırt çantasında bir oraya bir
buraya taşıyorsun öyle yatırıyorum çok
akıllısın her şeyi sen biliyorsun her
konuda çok kararlısın kimse sana kulları
nasıl Çünkü sen olduğun zaten yani her
şeyi biliyorsun en sevmediği şeyler
geliştirmek Ve beğenilmemek ve sana
verilen öğütler bitmeyen öğütler doğru
hatırlayın Emin hepimiz bunları yaşadık
ve en fenası daha yoğun çok başındasın
ve Bildiğim tek şey aslında bir şey
bilmedi ama o zaman böyle bir bilgi ve
ona geldi Anlat o çok hoşlandığınız
çocuk Bize 100 vermediğinde Ders
notlarını hızlıca bir şekilde düşmeye
başladığında almamızda burnumuzda
sivilceler çıkmaya başladı da yan
Sınıftaki kız gibi saçlarımız olmadığını
fark ettiğimizde bizim için hayat berbat
bağladı yaşama gerek yok Her şey bitti
çıkış yok En ufak ve o vakitler zaman
bahsediyorum
hayatım yaşanılmaz bir yer olduğunu
karar veriyorsunuz derdi hepimiz
İnanıyorum buna hemen hemencecik orada
orada çıktı artık Tamam hayatım devam
etmek istemiyorum Neşe gitti mi Evet
öldü ve tek yapmak istediğim o da bana o
zaman ki sevdiğim şarkılardan olgun
altına bire böyle büyür almak
bizim zamanımızda bulalım bu şekilde
geliyordu
buldum biz böyle bir verdik Şimdi de
Teknoloji değişti filan farklı formlar
oluşmuştur Hani bunalıma daha farklı
gidiyordur dinçler bilmiyorum ama bizim
dönemimizde Biz bulalı hakkıyla
hatırlayın Lütfen böyle böyle karışık ve
maksimum
günlüklerim izle o depresyonu O
bir saniye değişecek bir görüntü veya
bir şey açtı bir
şeyler yoktu o yüzden 28 doğumlu biri
olarak Ben de kendimden büyük bir bu
yaşayan insanların alımlarına hayranıdır
Çünkü Bizler hep olana kadar şey yıkama
Biz dibine kadar yaşadı
bana çıkıp dese ki doğal hayatı ciddi ya
hayat yaşamaması gereken çok çiftliğinde
Çok güzeller ve Daha önünde çok
zorluklar çok başka dertler var oğlanı
da sevinciyle dese sopayla kovalar çok
mu o zaman bunu anlayabilmek mümkün
değil ama şimdi 43 yaşında bir kadın
toplumda bir sanatçı ve iki çocuk annesi
olarak diyorum ki hayat
O çok ciddiye alınması gereken
mucizelerle dolu bitiş gibi deneyim ve
çok ciddiye almam gereken tek şey yani
şeyse kendisi sensin ayakkabı almak
vermek geçen bir saniye diye düşürmek ve
yaşamak çok güzel yaşamak çok kıymetli
şey çok güzel bir şey ben buraya bu
fikri bu duyguları gelene kadar o kadar
çok şey geçti ki Başımdan her bölümün
ortasında tüm başarısızlıklarında
takıldı tüm sorunlarda ve hataların da
yıkılan hayallerimde gerçekleşmeye
bisikletlerinde
başarısızlıklarını da sevmeyi çok erken
yaşta öğrendiğimi düşünüyorum çünkü
Mucizeler ve olan bu müthiş dediğimi
yaşamak istiyorum ya benim için mutluluk
buydu önce kendinde yola çıkmış
almalıydım özelliklerini niyetlerini
fark etmeliydim Böylece sevdiğim
okulları kazanıp ileride aşkla yapacağım
her şeyiyle oyunculuk bana getirecek Ben
konuşmayı seviyorum insanları seviyorum
diye dua TRT kurumlarında otobüslere bir
sunucuda tuzluklar yapıp yayınlar soğuk
şimdiki kariyer meslek oluşturduğumda
daha da önemlisi
babacığım da beraber soyadımın ötesine
geçtiğinde ve kendimi kimseye artık
ispatlamak ve tanıtmak zorunda
kalmadığında hayatım değişik hayatım
değişti ve gelişti artık parmakla
gösterilmek birçok farklı geliyor ve 25
senedir böyle Çünkü bir şeyler başardım
kendim de yok arkadaşlarım boş aldım
Babam burada ve soyadım seviyorum ve ben
bir şeyleri başarabilirim İşte o zaman
hayatım değişti hem de değişti başarmak
çok güzel bir şey
boşalmakta çok güzel bir şey ben buradan
da izleyecek genç arkadaşlarım burada
biz de olan genç şarkıcı evlatlarıma hep
şunu söylemek istiyorum dene O Ses
Türkiye izle düş başaramama tıkladım kal
depresyonları biliyorduk aşağısı çek Ben
her zaman yanındayım Çünkü başaramadı
zaman Aslı başka şey de başarıyorsunuz
başaramadı zaman müthiş şeyler
kazanıyorsun da inanıyorum Bu canlı bir
örneği
kendi sıradanlığın içindeki kendi
özelliklerini bulma yolculuğu biliyordum
Aslında bu ya Buraya kadar Bundan sonra
olacağını bilmiyorum ama yaralandıkça
kendini sevmeye başlıyorsun kendini
tanımaya ve Kimseye Kendini kıyaslama ya
başlıyorsun ve bunları dediğinde Çevre
ne der Elalem Dede Bunlar düşünüyor
yerine Ben hangisini daha çok istiyorum
benim paşa keyfini şu anda ne yapmak
istiyorum canım ne çekiyor kim kimi
aldırmıyor kimi acı Seni seviyorum hangi
çiçeği alayım Neyi suyun toprağın
basında bin pijamalı bütünü yatayım ve
çalışmanın dışında kendine
bu alanlarında birleştirdiğim zaman
Candida hissediyoruz konuşmamı
başlarında bahsetmiştim ve takip
çaldığımız içinde bir yabancı gibiyiz
ergenliğin izle ve o yaşlarımız da diye
artık bir zaman sonra o yabancı çıkıyor
Onu ele tutuşuyoruz var basıyoruz artık
evinize yabancı değilsiniz iyi günde
kötü günde hastalıkta ve sağlıkta
eğlenceli en sıkıyorlar arkadaşım önceki
Şimdi bunu söyleyebilirim
başarılarından sonra başarısızlığı nasıl
edin diyebilirim iyi bir yol arkadaşım
kendim için bütün bu deneyimleri Az
evvel de söylediğim gibi birinci 90'lı
yıllarda tek geliyor 90'lar Bu sırada
Çok önemli çünkü 90'larda İnci pop
müziği yani çok önemli başka hiçbir şey
yokmuşçasına Bir de benim o acele
Yıllarım her şeyin 90'larda toplanıyor
bakıldığında
sevdiğimiz hocam güzel söylemişti Bende
çok başka bir hayata gidebilirdim benim
yap Ne oldu kardeşlikte çocuk Ankara'da
Keşke fotoğrafı sayım Sonra çok pişman
olduğu Ankara'da bir apartmanın bodrum
katında babam bütünlüğü tiyatroda
annenin Devleti yapılarında kiralık
yapıyor e kişilere gidiyor bir okumaya
çalışıyorlar ve burslu okuyan bir
öğrenciyim annem babam pat diye
ayrılıyor dersleri hiçbir yediği sadece
yaratıcılık ve sanat derslerinde çok
iyiyim Ama diğer derslerde öğretmenler
haklarından şöyle falan içiyor Yani bu
örneği neden veriyorum almıyor
Aklım almıyor Ya böyle Özgür Bırakın
diyorum ya ben bakın böyle şeyler
yapıyorum yani beni tiyatro kolunda
soktuğunu final ederim Fidan Gibi yani
hani o beceremedim daha size çok iyi
boyun koyayım çok iyi dans gösterisi
yapayım kendi içindeki asla paylaşıp
beni oradan başka bir yere koymalarını
çalışacağım şimdi anlıyorum O zaman işte
o zor ve sıkıntılı olabilecek hayatı
Çiçek Bu ne ya başladığımı farkettim
Dünya çok merak ettim Çok meraklı bir
insanım Çok araştırmayı çok severim
dünyanın birçok yerine gittim küçücük
bir programı biriktirdim dünyaya
geldiğin kaleler satılan Tiyatrosu olur
her yeri okumayı çok seviyorum
araştırmayı çok seviyorum tarihe merak
saldım Bu konuda da
ileride bir mesleğim daha olabilecek
kadar meraklıyım çok sesli müziğe çok
büyük gönlümü verdim bir çok önemli bir
su maç almayı denedim bir saatte
karşındaki çok kıymetli hocalardan bebek
ne oldu gitti çok
eğlenceli ve
ve yeteneklerimi anıların hayallerini
Yalnız kendi kumaşından diyebileceğim
elbiseleri dikmeyi öğrendiğim zaman ben
de ışık yandı Belki sevgilim Oo şu gibi
olmak zorunda değilim devamlı başarıya
koşmak devamını yıldızlı pekiyi almak
zorunda değilim en bakımlı en güzel en
sevilen ve en sevilen olmak için
insanların istediği cümleleri kurmak
zorunda değilim okulda popüler olmak
için o kızın giydiği elbiseyi kantinde
durmak zorunda değil kilimden bu soruyla
başlıyor kimdim kimden Benim kendime ait
bir parmak izim olduğu gibi hepimizin
olduğu gibi kendime ait bir hayatım
olduğundan ne istiyorum eminim hepiniz
istediklerini mutlu bir insan olmak
istiyorum sorular canlarını alacaksın
görünce mutlu oluyor yani bunu belki
gelişim Okulu'nda saçma acaba o
oluşturdum doğru Şimdi anlıyorum o kadar
önemli ki Çok sevmek istiyorum Çok
sevilmek istiyorum ve iyi o güzelliğin
peşinde koşmak istiyorum Bu biçimde
birçok
çok sevdiğim gönlümü verdiğim insanlarla
çalışıyorum Bu daha kendimi çok iyi
hissettiriyor bunu olduğu iyi tamamlamak
istiyorum işe yarar kayde değer
insanları dokunmak istiyorum haber ver
gene sevgili senin çocuğun aktardığı
gibi birileri elini tutmak istiyorum hiç
tanımadığım insanlarla iletişim kurmak
istiyorum ve bu hayatta bütün
tecrübelerle buraya gelebileceğini
düşünüyorum Çünkü her yeni gün her yeni
bir kapı beceremedik Ç başka bir
parkurdan koşmaya çalışmamız lazım hem
işte bir kalsın resimlerindeki gibi
bakış açımızı değiştirmemiz lazım Çünkü
bizi çok sıkıyor şey var
uygunsuzlukların sucuklar Hayal
kırıklıkları bize bakış açılarını
değiştirip Kendimizden başka bir dersin
çıkarırsak bir şey olacak buna
inanıyorum şunları rica ediyorum genç
arkadaşlarına Başak eğitimimize göre
hayatınızı yaşayın kaçamam larımızı
yapıp çok disiplinli olur birşey ne
demek için tekrar edin hergün kendinize
öğrenebilmek için zaman yaratın işinize
çok aşkla sarılıp geç kalmayın
tutamayacağınız sözler vermeyin hiç
kimseye saygısız etmeyi unutmayın
karşınızdaki insanlar o an bizim
hissettiğimiz durumda olmak zorunda
değiller empati yapın bütün hayatımız
değişecek olabildiğince çok aşık olur
Mümkünse Çünkü şunu söyledi azaltıp bir
şey bu çok net Söyleyebilirim ama şu an
yanınızda mutlak bir kahraman olacak yol
arkadaşınız olacak yine dişim gibi geç
bulduğumu iki buldum dediğim bir
kahramanı oldu benim için bol Yaramazlık
yapıp o yaramazlık her şey olabilir
kontrolü kaybetmekten korkuyorum
diyorlar bazı genç arkadaşlar Kaybet En
Son Nerede bıraktıysan Orada bir şekilde
bulacaksın dünya döndükçe
asla insanların bize hakkında
söyledikleri duyguların gerçekliğini
katılmayı kendinizi değiştirip topu
mayası kalmayın kendi ne var ettiğiniz
evlerinizi keşfettiğimiz zaman o
mucizelerle dolu hayatı göreceksiniz
özgürlüğünüzü özünüzü sözünüzü sesinizi
fikirlerinizi hiç kimse hiçbir
ideolojinin değiştirmesi Ne Olur İzin
vermeyin hayattaki sağlamlığa
[Müzik]
vermek arasında geçen bir saniye de
içine nasıl dolduracağız sadece güzellik
ve bunu sadece biz karar veririz
sanırım ben o zor sayılabilecek M
çağlarında engelleri böyle aşkım şimdi
bunlardan çok tarihinin ve Evet 17'lik
Doğan İyi ki varsın İyi ki babanın
kızısın İyi ki baba Aziz kaybolmuş İyi
ki gurur da elinden tutabileceği bir
babam gelir soyadını olmuş İyi ki oğlum
mutfağıyla dedesinin ismi ile yaşayacak
ve eğer beni acıtan beni zorlayan beni
üzen ve devam edemeyeceğini ilerleyen da
düşündüren her şey benim için çok ama
çok güzelmiş Benim için püf noktası bu
işi tersine çevirmekle buldum Aslında
yolculuğu huzurlarınızda çıkmış 6
yakaladım Siz güzel insanların önünde
gençlik tercih tecrübelerine büyüttüğü
eğittiği geliştirdiği mutlu ettiği
başarılı ve başarılı kaptırdığı
beceremediğimiz sandım her olaya rağmen
beni işini aşkla yapan bağımsızca kendi
Ayaklarında 25 senin özgürce duymamızı
sağlayan özü sözü bir kimseden topu
çekilmeyen devamlı üreten gelişen
geliştiren servis edilen Bir kız bir
oğlan evlat sahibi bi anne sabırlı
şefkatli bir
anne ve çok sevgiliye eşe dönüştürücü
için son olarak diyorum ki bu da dahil
bütün
yanlışsa benimkiler de dahil Burada
sıraladım her şey sadece bir iticiler
dilerim sizler ve bizler Bu ethics
konuşmalı bünyesi izleyecek olan herkes
kendi yolunu kendi püf noktasını kendisi
bozuk Çok teşekkür ederim bildiğiniz o